ici on transforme les déchets non
recyclables comme des sacs plastiques
des vieilles chaussures en des pierres
et des chèques que tu vois là c'est des
déchets qu'on appelle des déchets
industriels qui sont pour le commun des
mortels équivalent des déchets des
déchetteries municipales donc c'est des
mix de plastique de papier de carton de
bois et donc aujourd'hui il devrait
aller en enfouissement principalement ou
en incinération
l'enfouissement c'est relativement
évident que c'est un problème parce que
c'est les grandes décharges qu'on voit
avec les colonies de mouettes donc bah
tu condames un sol pour l'éternité et
mais factuellement ce qui nous dérange
c'est les émissions de CO2 qui sont
associés à l'enfouissement parce que
quand tu as un site d'enfouissement tu
as de la décomposition de matière
organique au fond qui crée du méthane et
c'est fuite de méthane elles vont
émettre beaucoup plus que du CO2
l'incinération de son côté ça rejette
pas mal de CO2 parce que tu brûles des
plastiques c'est comme si tu brûlais du
pétrole c'est pas parce que c'est un
déchet que c'est tout de suite
renouvelable donc nous on vient avec une
troisième solution la fossilisation
qui a vraiment pour objectif d'arrêter
l'enfouissement et l'incinération
d'arrêter d'émettre autant de CO2 et en
plus d'en faire un de faire de la
séquestration carbone donc faire de ces
petits cailloux du de des pluies de
carbone ici c'est notre site à
shazen-sur-loire donc c'est là qu'on a
commencé on a créé la boîte en 2019 avec
deux autres associés dont mon père qui
est celui qui a eu l'idée de la
fossilisation et donc aujourd'hui sur le
site on est à peu près 180 salariés et
on commence à déployer des usines chez
les clients donc des ce qu'on appelle
des fossilisateurs donc qui nous
permettront de traiter par usine à peu
près 10 000 tonnes de déchets par an un
fossilisateur de 10000 tonnes ça évite
et séquestre à peu près 5000 tonnes de
CO2 par an est-ce qu'il représente à peu
près 200000 arbres comme si on plantait
200000 arbres la première étape de la
fossilisation c'est un broyage l'idée
c'est de transformer le flux d'échecs à
vue tout à l'heure en cette farine donc
un flux micronisé très fin et cette
farine on va pouvoir la faire agir avec
notre client dans le malaxeur tu vois là
en fait la farine passe par tout c'est
partout ce chemin est mis en contact
avec notre client dans ce malaxeur là
dedans se fait la réaction chimique qui
nous intéresse à la fin de la réaction
on obtient une pâte et cette pâte elle
va être emmenée jusqu'à la presse pour
faire des granulats après liaisons notre
notre déchet avec notre client ça
ressemble à cette patte là donc c'est
cette pâte qu'on met dans la presse pour
sortir des petits granulats tu les
laisses reposer en gros une semaine et
du coup après une semaine on a des
granulats donc aussi résistant à peu
près que des granules naturels qui sont
vraiment durs et on peut en faire on
peut en faire de la construction c'est
comme des graviers en fait tu vois les
granulats c'est la base de la
construction on en utilise pour faire
des routes on en utilise pour faire du
béton un béton c'est simple c'est du
ciment du sable et du caillot nous on
remplace le caillou là-dedans les
cailloux c'est on en consomme 450
millions de tonnes par an en France donc
après l'eau c'est la ressource la plus
utilisée
ici c'est la partie laboratoire on a à
peu près une petite cinquantaine de
personnes qui travaillent sur plein
d'aspects différents à la fois sur notre
chimie donc le liant qui permet de faire
la fossilisation mais aussi sur
l'amélioration des granulats en faire
des granulats les plus résistants
possible et aussi l'amélioration
environnementale des granulats prouver à
chaque à chaque échantillonnage que on
n'a pas de problème de polluants
potentiel qui est relargué dans la
nature c'est le premier truc qui nous
vient à l'esprit quand on fait des des
matériaux à partir de déchets c'est ce
que c'est pas dangereux est-ce qu'il y a
pas des polluants vous êtes sûr de pas
relâcher justement des polluants ouais
aujourd'hui en fait on a on a toutes les
confirmations on vient de recevoir un
nouveau rapport en plus de lineris qui
est institut responsable des risques
industriels qui prouvent que nos
granulés posent pas de dangerosité donc
aujourd'hui on se concentre
exclusivement sur les déchets
industriels qui sont les déchets que tu
as vu tout à l'heure donc soit les
déchets des entreprises soit le les
encombrants de déchetterie et demain ce
qu'on veut faire c'est les ordures
ménagères c'est donc l'autre moitié du
gisement de déchets en France 15
millions de tonnes par an qui sont
majoritairement incinérés et aussi un
peu fruits et donc le but du jeu c'est
de réussir à les traiter comme on traite
le reste et donc là les échantillons que
tu as là c'est les premiers essais de
réaction chimiques entre notre liant et
ce type de déchets qui est assez spécial
parce que il y a des restes alimentaires
dedans qu'il faut savoir gérer
et donc on pense dans cette capable
d'industrialiser la solution d'ici deux
ans à peu près si demain on arrive à
traiter les ordures ménagères en plus
des déchets qu'on arrive à traiter
aujourd'hui le potentiel à l'échelle de
la France c'est une réduction de peu
près 7% des émissions françaises de CO2
donc ça c'est considérable le
gouvernement a annoncé une réduction de
30% de nos émissions d'ici 2030 nous on
peut en apporter 7% et c'est je pense
aussi grâce à des techno comme ça qu'on
va pouvoir y arriver en plus de tous les
efforts qu'on doit mettre sur la
sobriété
[Musique]